today we will talk about a large
enterprise
called big corp limited they want to
centralize access control
to their web apps both internal and
external
charlie how could they do that with
google cloud platform
well right now there are a lot of
different groups of admins and
developers controlling websites at big
corp limited and they use a lot of
different frameworks and languages
we're going to see how google cloud
platform can help them control access to
all those sites
without having to change them will all
be centralized control instead
[Music]
let me introduce you to marissa she's a
systems administrator at big corp
limited
and her team has to manage access to all
these different web
systems she has to solve all these
problems that charlie told us about a
minute ago
marissa and her team has outlined four
different use cases
first big corp's public website of
course needs to be accessible by anybody
out there on the internet anonymous
users
second their support area of their
website
needs to be accessible by anybody as
well but we have to know who it is
users have to log in so they only see
their own support tickets
third employees at the company and and
contractors and occasional other people
who are on the
inside of the company will need to be
able to see the intranet
of uh and their internal web
applications
and fourth some employees in certain
uh teams like support team that will get
to see
customer pii personal identifiable data
but
only if they are on secured machines
so uh charlie can the gold cloud
platform help marissa with these
four access levels yes it can i've been
in marissa's situation a previous job
and also created new web services that
require user authentication
and access control so i know this can be
a
very challenging technological
management
and configuration issue but google cloud
platform has a tool that can help
enormously
it's called identity aware proxy it's a
great fit for marissa and her developers
and it's a service that controls access
to those websites for them the nice
thing is
it can do this without changing those
web servers in any way
oh that sounds great like just the
ticket for marissa
how would this actually work in practice
well let's take a look at an example
here we've got an internet-facing
website
that needs to control access and it's
got three potential users on this
picture uh the general public somebody
that doesn't
authenticate themselves at all a real
authorized user
and then somebody that can authenticate
they've got credentials but they're not
one of the people the site wants to talk
to
so right now all of their requests hit
this web server and it's the web
server's responsibility decide
which ones to respond to and which ones
to ignore
identity aware proxy is a service that
sits
right here between the server
and the internet all of the requests
coming from the internet to the web
server now go through identitywhere
proxy
identitywhere proxy prompts the users to
log in
and after they log in it uses their
identity and marissa's configuration to
decide who to let through
and only requests coming specifically
from
the authorized users ever actually hit
the web server
at all now in order to do this
the users do have to log in and they use
google's identity service
which handles gmail and g suite
basically
all of those different possible
addresses
okay that sounds pretty good but how
about
if big corp isn't using a google
identity i know
for example my last employer before
google they use active directory instead
that's certainly pretty common and um
google solves that with iep as well
marissa's corp can synchronize their
active directory
with the google identity service and
then all the users in their active
directory can be verified by google
and used to configure iap once iep knows
who each user is
it can simply block the users it should
not come through the website
they can't see it at all and the web
server doesn't need to worry about
did that is that somebody we should
respond to or not because it never even
gets a request
in the first place nice uh yeah anybody
who's had a web server on the public
internet knows that you get a lot of
weird
traffic that you probably don't want to
see absolutely
uh so so charlie uh this looks good and
we can keep
uh the unauthorized users out but but
what if that web server over there on
the left
actually needs to know who is accessing
well this picture shows iap controlling
who can come through
and have their requests come to the web
server but iop has another trick up its
sleeve
that i really love when it sends a
request through it
it adds a header in fact it adds three
headers and those headers
include the identity of the user that
authenticated iap
so now if the web server does want to
know who that user is
they can just check a header which is
hard to have something easier than that
in any kind of a web server framework
and so i can find the email address it
can find a persistent
id there's a lot of information that's
available in those headers
okay cool you mentioned different uh
frameworks and platforms uh
what and of course maurice's company
they have lots of different frameworks
and platforms
uh which of these does ip work with
as you'd expect iap can protect services
running on a lot of google cloud
platform infrastructure
such as app engine compute engine and
pretty much anything that can be behind
a cloud load balancer but it also
can protect stuff on the company's own
premises using something called iap
connector
that's going to require some extra
network configuration to
route the requests from iap back onto
the company's own premises
but once it's set up then it's
configured for access just like any of
the other
things behind ip all this is
straightforward
okay it looks pretty straightforward
here in slide form
uh how would merce actually go in and
set this up in in
real practical terms all right well i've
set up a
demo project on google cloud platform
with five
sample websites let's take a look at
that on the console
here we see the console control page for
app engine and there are five websites
set up here for app engine
one of them is the public one at just
plain big corp ltd.com
there's one for customers to send in
support requests
one for the customer support staff to
respond to them and a couple of internal
websites for different purposes
one that's open to all employees one
that's more restricted
iap can configure all of these
situations
now right now all five of these websites
are wide open
because we haven't enabled iep and we're
going to fix that
right yeah that doesn't seem very safe
is there some way marisa can
not expose the company internal stuff
not even for a minute not even for a
second
well it turns out that in order to turn
on iap to protect something
something needs to be there already so
in what i would do is i would just
deploy a simple hello world website so i
can enable iap
and then when i put more websites out
the same project they would be protected
by default
and i could then configure them to
whatever way i wanted them to be so they
could all be a little bit different
okay so let's get started here we have
our app engine project with a lot of
websites to protect so we've got to turn
iap aware
identity where proxy on for it using the
cloud console
the cloud console menu has the different
commands
organized in groups and iap is under the
security group
identitywhere proxy
so here we see all the different https
that is
web servers that are protectable by iap
all those app engine ones are to protect
them
all i got to do is flip this toggle
that's it they're protected now if this
were the first time i ever
turned on iap in this project i would be
prompted to fill in a form
for what we call the uh consent screen
and that basically is describing
who's asking the user to log in so when
google puts the log screen up it can say
this is for bigcorpltv.com that's who
you're logging into
all right uh so now
this is set up here and
what happens if you hit the public
website now
well it takes a few minutes for changes
to iep to propagate because it's a
worldwide service
but once that's done we'll open a fresh
incognito browser so there's no
logged in user already cached
and try to connect the corporate website
and i'm immediately asked to sign in
i can sign in with my big corp lpd.com
account
oh you work at big corp charlie i didn't
know
just temporarily and now we see that if
he is blocking me
uh-oh so but that
is a little weird because i did not see
you turn off access
for anybody charlie i did not
tell ip to deny anybody access but i
turned on iap and i didn't tell it to
let anybody in either
and that's the way it works if he
doesn't say who to keep out it says who
to let in
so we're going to need to go into tell
iap to let users into this public site
so let's go ahead and configure the
public site
remember the use cases we were looking
at the first one is
everybody in the world should be able to
get to it this is just a regular
public commercial website
yeah so this seems like a little odd i
think for iep because it worked it was
public for everybody a minute ago
we now turned it off uh with ip do we
even need ip
in this for this use case well yes this
is kind of an odd use case
because we had a site that was already
open to the public we turned on iep
nobody's
allowed in and now we're going to
configure iap to let everybody in again
the reason for this is that iep is
global across this project
so the public website is in the same
google cloud project as the other ones
so when i turn on iap it affects it as
well
luckily i can tell iap pretend you're
not there let the public through
let's go ahead and do that right now
take a look at how we configure it
here we see the public website which is
the default one
when we select it we have an info panel
that shows who's got
various access to this site and what we
want to do is add a member to the site
this is how we let somebody through
and we just need to put say their email
addresses so we can put
everybody's email address in the world
here but that's not really what we want
to do
so there's a special case whoops
that i need to type all users as a
special iap user
to give anybody access i need to give
them an iap secure webax
web app user save that
tell it yes i want to allow public
access and remember it'll take a couple
minutes
but now after that's propagated
when somebody goes to that website they
won't even see iap at all they won't be
prompted to log in
they'll just be sent directly to the
site okay
we've waited a couple of minutes so the
changes should be propagated
let's open a fresh incognito web browser
so nobody's been logged into anything
through it yet
and it'll take a second to go through
didn't prompt me to log in anybody in
the world was allowed to connect
just as if we didn't have iap at all
there are probably easier ways to
save that than turning on iap and then
configuring it but we're going to see
more valuable uses of iap in a few
minutes
i see that big corp like a minimalist uh
web design it was very minimal
design yes yes
all right so cool that was public access
perhaps the simplest use case and maybe
the least
interesting one let's move on to the
second one i think this is a lot more
interesting so
users anybody can log in but they must
be authenticated
how does ip do this from the iap
management point of view
this is almost identical we want to iep
to let everybody through
however we're saying before you let them
through authenticate them
and pass through headers telling us who
you authenticated them as
so if we go back to the console instead
of default we go to the support site the
general public will use
and again we add a member and the only
difference here is instead of adding all
users
we had the special use case all
authenticated users
again we grant them the role of an iap
secured web app user
save it and warns that we're making it
available to the public but only
authenticated members of the public
and after it propagates and we connect
to it
we'll see that the site knows who we are
okay so let's go in a fresh incognito
browser
and go to that customer support site
support dot
big corp limited
now we told them to let everybody
through but we said authenticate them
before you let them through
i'm going to use the same dummy email
account but it really doesn't matter
which one i use it could be anybody
that google can authenticate
whoops and it can only authenticate me
if i type the password in right
now it will pass me through to the
account
take a second for the website to spin up
to respond and notice that
it says welcome angle key at
bigquarklt.com
the website knows michael that's your
email i didn't have to do anything
i didn't have to log into the website
iap told the website who it was
so how does ip do that how does this
work
well the way it knows that let's go look
at the picture we had earlier
of all the intercept of all your tests
coming in and being intercepted
and adding headers these are the headers
that it adds
three headers one called x goog
authenticated user email
then x goog authenticated user id
and xgoog iap jwt assertion
here are some examples of the values the
authenticated user email one
is my email address that iap verifies it
stands by saying i really checked that's
who this really is
uh the user id is uh oh kind of an
opaque identifier that google uses
so that every time i go to the website
i'll have the same identifier
but the website won't necessarily know
that my email address that way it could
store that if it wanted to
only give me my response back but
without storing something potentially
sensitive like an email address
the final one's a little bit more
complicated
it's the jwt header what is that jrwt
header
well i'm not showing it all goes on and
on and on
it's a very long base64 encoded string
that represents a digitally signed
record that has a user id and email in
it which you know from the other headers
anyway
but the fact is depending on how the
company's servers are configured
particularly if you're on your own data
center you may have
the path from the internet to your web
server that has to go through iep
but you may have other paths from other
machines inside your data center network
that can set request iep and if you're
concerned that those
other machines in your data center could
be compromised
they could send fake requests to that
web server and they could add a header
that says this is my email address even
though it really isn't
the assad the digitally signed jwt
can't be spooked because it's digitally
signed by google with google's private
key
so the website can simply verify it and
decode it
and make sure that it didn't get spooked
so in the description below this video
we've got a link that
points to the documentation on things
like jwt
in general and there's a code lab
specifically on how to decode that
with a flask python program that's being
protected with iep
okay so what i'm hearing is many
developers for many developers it'll be
enough to just look at the email or user
id header
but if you want additional security
within um
your your project or data center then uh
you may want to verify the jwt header
yes
the more control of networking options
that are in use
the more pads there might be to the
server on the back
end that don't go through the front door
and then you'd be concerned about it but
in a case like this with app engine
there aren't any such paths for our
example
so we can do it the simple way oh okay
oh excellent
all right cool so we talked about two
the first two use cases they're about
public access to the website
now what about the third use case uh so
remember this was the one where
only big corp employees should be able
to hit their internal web apps
yeah that everybody needs to do and
when people first started doing these
internet sites they would just take an
unprotected web server
but put it on the internal company
network so anybody else that's on the
internal company network can get to it
people who aren't
can't get to it great but it opened a
lot of other problems what's wrong with
that
that website now trusted everybody
on the internal company network every
device that was there which might not be
a good idea
an even bigger problem that occurred
over time is employees are less and less
likely to be in the main office and
connected to that internal network
they'd be on the road
so the solution to that was let's set up
a virtual private network so they can
connect
to the internal network through the
internet as if they were on the internal
network
that gave him the access but it opened
up again a whole new set of problems
it was hard to configure and support and
it meant that this outside machine now
had access to everything
not just the employee's website iap
gives us another solution
so remember the picture
of how iap protected access
all of the requests had to go through it
and it only let a request through if it
was one of the users you wanted
so marissa can simply configure iep and
say only let through people who really
are employees who can authenticate and
prove their employees
so the web requests that come through
iep will just be this kind of request
that might have come in your internal
network from employees
you're protected from all the rest of
the internet and
the end user doesn't need to have a vpn
client or anything else they can just
connect with any web browser
so long as they can authenticate
themselves
now configuring this is very similar to
what we've seen before
so let's go back to that console and
let's go to the employee website
and we need to add a member that
represents all the employees
well marissa's company uh synchronizes
uh
their active directory for all email
addresses at big corp ltd.com
to google so all they need to do is say
dot bigcorpltd.com and every one of
those email addresses is now allowed and
no others are
typically they may have other people
that want to treat his employees for the
internet
but who they don't want to give email
addresses to maybe their temps or their
contractors so they can set up a group
with all those email addresses
and they can add the group as well they
don't have to enter each individual
address
and then hr can manage that group as new
temps come in and new contractors go out
while enabling it it's the same thing
we've seen twice before give them the
iap secured web app
user role
and now in a few minutes we're not going
to wait and show it because the same
kind of thing we've seen before
but anybody that tries to go this
employee site will be intercepted by ap
and only if they're an employee or one
of these people in that group of temps
and contractors
will they get through let's look at the
customer support
site that the cut that the customer
support staff uses
they're going to log in and they're
going to see the request from users and
they're going to see those users email
addresses
which we don't want the public in any
case ever to be able to get to so we
want to make sure that not only are the
people connecting a member of the
customer support staff
but if they're using say a personal
laptop that they don't use something
that doesn't have a screen lock
and they leave it logged in they walk
away for a minute somebody steals it
they're still logged into the site you
can see this data we want to make sure
that we can't have that happen
so marissa's company said we want the
support staff to be able to connect when
they're remote that's
very very common and we want to restrict
it to only those staff but we want to go
further
we only want them to connect if they're
using a machine that has a screen lock
enabled
and has the hard drive encrypted so if
the device is lost it doesn't give the
person who takes it
access to that site
oh uh can iop do that does it know when
machines have been stolen
yes it can um this is one last little
trick iep has for the moment
uh configuring to do that looks a lot
like the other use cases with a little
bit of a twist at the end
let's go ahead and take a look and do
that
so here we see the iap page and the
customer support
website we're going to add members of
the customer support group
and we're going to give them iap secured
web
app user but before we say go ahead and
save this
we're going to add a restriction
only let them do it if they're
connecting from a machine that meets the
needs
of a safer client
now when somebody from the customer
support group logs in
even if they properly authenticate they
won't be let through if they're on a
machine that doesn't have a screen lock
or doesn't have an encrypted hard drive
now that's all configured in access
context manager
here's that safer client policy you can
see it says devices have to have a
device screen lock
and they have to have encryption turned
on
just for a quick look there are a lot of
other things that can be put in as well
if they were appropriate
for example they can restrict access to
specific ip
network ranges they can also restrict
access to certain regions
perhaps they want to only allow people
to access it from the us and canada
or only from european union countries
they can select those countries
and only those people will come through
the device policy we are using can be
made more restrictive the machine not
only might have to have a screen lock
and encrypted storage
but maybe it also has to be a machine
that's been specifically approved or
even a machine that the company owns
and it can also restrict which operating
systems and operating system versions
are allowed i'm not going to add any of
those conditions
uh because this is strong enough for
what marissa's company needs
now in order to do that
iep needs to know some stuff about the
end user's machine
like the screen lock and the encryption
level that a browser normally won't tell
a web server normally it wouldn't tell
iep that
so the users are going to have to have a
work profile on their phone or a chrome
extension in their browser
that tells them that that's available
for anybody if they are using g
suite and are connected to a corporate
profile it'll do that automatically
and that basically says when you're
connected to iap for
our company let it know this information
about your machine so it can decide what
level of access to provide
and that's it iap can handle all these
four
four use cases which are pretty
universal uh there's a lot of different
ways you can figure it and fine-tune it
but the nice thing about it is marisa
can do that and the app
servers that are out there don't have to
change at all oh nice
i think big cork will eventually be able
to delete
a lot of their authentication code
they're sprinkled all over the web apps
i think so so thank you
thank you for showing us this charlie
and uh thank you all for
tuning in if you have questions about
how iep works or any security questions
on gcp
and serverless please post them as in
comments below
or if you have questions about or
requests for other videos we should
create around serverless please let us
know
thank you for this time see you next
time
[Music]
you